Speaker 1: You know, one of the questions
we've been asking during this historic anti-vaccine
era around the world because of the COVID
vaccines, is is it going to is anti-vax going
to start to bleed over to more general vaccine
opposition, not just the COVID vaccine?
What about measles?
What about MMR and others?
And so far, the answer appears to be unfortunately
yes.
And this was very predictable.
There's a good article in The Guardian.
Measles cases surge nearly 80% in the wake
of COVID chaos, with fears other diseases
could follow.
UNICEF says virus is canary in the coal mine
that shows up.
I think I think it's supposed to say shows
us the gaps in vaccination campaigns for preventable
illness.
Measles cases have surged nearly 80% worldwide
amid disruption caused by COVID.
The UN says the coronavirus pandemic has interrupted
vaccination campaigns for non-covid diseases
around the world, creating a perfect storm
that could put millions of children's lives
at risk.
A measles is a disease caused by a virus that
attacks mainly children.
Vaccination uptake of at least 95% is the
way to avoid it spreading.
Some countries fall short of that goal.
Somalia at just 46%.
There's also concerns about whether yellow
fever could surge.
There are concerns about the Ukrainian invasion
by Russia and the effect that that could have.
The U.N. says 57 vaccination campaigns in
43 countries have been postponed.
So this is focusing on access.
But the problem is we saw outbreaks in the
United States of measles before the COVID
pandemic.
So the point here is basically twofold.
Because of the pandemic, there have been campaigns
of vaccination that have been interrupted.
And they tell us how quickly you can see outbreaks
of something as contagious as measles, which
in particular is a problem among children
in the United States.
A big sort of battle line on the anti-vax
front is the vaccination of children.
Before we even had the COVID vaccines in this
controversy, we had some pretty good sized
measles outbreaks.
There was the Disneyland one in California.
There were some religious sects in New York
City where we were seeing outbreaks.
There was one in Italy, a couple others that
I can't remember.
These outbreaks were in part based on the
idea that parents didn't want to vaccinate
their kids.
Now, with measles, understand how critical
that is, particularly when it's so contagious
that you need to be vaccinating 95%.
It is a concern right now that we are going
to start seeing as more and more kids come
up for vaccination boosters, for other diseases,
or as more and more kids are born and it's
time for them to get the shots that babies
get in the first six months.
We are almost certainly going to see some
more general vaccine hesitancy on the basis
of COVID vaccine hesitancy, and it's going
to lead to more of some of these diseases.
And the measles pre-COVID example is one of
the best ones, just small areas where they
said, I don't I don't want to vaccinate my
kid against measles.
And they had outbreaks.
And it's very serious for kids.
It could get very, very bad.
And so while on the one hand, we're fighting
the vaccination battle on COVID, specifically,
there's this other more general Anti-Vaxx
thing that is beneath the surface.
And we've heard from some mean, you know,
look at the interviews we've seen from Trump
rallies where parents say, well, it's it's
not just the COVID vaccine.
I'm getting my kids off of all of these vaccines.
There is sometimes they call them, they say
they're injections.
They're not, strictly speaking, vaccines.
This could get very bad very quickly.
And we should be paying close attention to
the numbers from all over the world.
We'll have more about this story on our Instagram.
Make sure you're following us there at David
Pakman show.
We'll take a quick break.
We'll look at the White House Correspondents
Dinner.
We'll look at a few other things.
Be right back.